[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas d'édito prêt je n'ai pas de canapé
confinement oblige place à un nouvel
épisode de l'autre match en mode confiné
quelles conséquences du coronavirus sur
le sport d'un point de vue sanitaire
économique et sociale on en parle avec
nos invités gervais martel ex président
du racing club de lens est un christophe
lepetit responsable des études
économiques au centre d'économie et de
droit du sport de limoges l'euro 2020 un
reporter d'un an l'uefa qui veut que les
lignes domestiques s'achève à début août
pour jouer dans la foulée la ligue des
champions certains comme jean pierre
rivère le président de l'ogcnice ou jean
michel aulas le président de l'olympique
lyonnais souhaite une fin de championnat
de septembre à décembre la lfp annonce
une reprise éventuelle mi juin le
ministère des sports propose de
déconfinement le sport professionnel le
11 mai finir à huit clos gervais martel
on s'y perd
bonjour à vous quelle est votre position
et celle de vos joueurs à lens bah
écoutez je pense qu'on s'y perd c'est
sûr c'est un sacré bordel du mot mais
tout le monde parle sans arrêt change
d'avis proposé solutions qui sont
intenables notamment celles de deux
rivières qui est qui et pas mal jusqu'à
on pourrait jouer à peut-être un jour
soit les civils mais certains parce que
j'ai dû caler avec les championnats et
aidé à mort aux p un allemand ou
espagnol qui ont l'air de vouloir autant
moi personnellement je pense qu'on va
pas reprendre mais ça n'est que mon avis
on parlera de ce qui se passera au
niveau économique ensuite mais je pense
que ça va pas prendre parce que
aujourd'hui si on suit si on écoute les
spécialistes et dépendra aussi du mal à
s'y retrouver même s'ils ont des gens
formidables qui l'ont dit ils ont des
avis divergents où on peut croire au
moment où je vous parle qui est
seulement 6 % de la population qu'ils
soient touchées ça veut dire que quand
on va quand on va d confiné au 11 mai on
risque d'avoir quand même un peu plus de
gens touchés malheureusement je vois mal
comment le sport et notamment le
football qui est acquis quand même un
sport de contact on pourra gérer prendre
des entraînements et jouer des matches à
huis clos sans qu'ils puissent y avoir
éventuellement quelques problèmes de 2k
qui arrivent dans les équipes donc je
suis pas très optimiste pour la reprise
du coude
monde ça donne un peu de baume au coeur
d'annoncer qu'on va reprendre telle ou
telle date d'abord c'est un peu
compliqué parce que tout le monde a son
avis les avis divergent mais moi je vois
mal le foot reprendre dans les dans les
semaines qui viennent christophe lepetit
la lfp qui veulent reprendre un coup de
que coûte alors que par exemple les
gouvernements allemands et belges
interdisent des compétitions sportives
jusqu'au 31 août
ça veut dire quoi c'est urgences
économiques avant tout aux impératifs de
santé publique
je pense que chacun est dans son rôle
c'est à dire que la lfp est une
organisatrice des compétitions
professionnelles de football et à ce
titre là et bien essayé de savoir à quel
moment elle pourra reprendre ses
compétitions
parce que parce qu'effectivement il ya
des enjeux économiques qui te sont loin
d'être neutres pour pour les clubs et
pour l'économie du football en général
et donc c'est tout à fait finalement
logique qu'elle cherche à établir des
scénarios de reprise pour essayer de
savoir si elle reprend au 1er juin au 15
juin ou plus tard maintenant c'est
évident que face à ça ce sont les enjeux
sanitaires qui prendront le dessus qui
ce sont les décisions du gouvernement
français qui s'imposeront décisions qui
sont prises sur la base notamment des
des médecins qui composent le conseil
scientifique et des recommandations de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé donc
chacun est dans son rôle
la lfp réfléchit à différentes
hypothèses de travail qui tombent les
unes après les autres au fur et à mesure
qu'on avance dans le temps
même hypothèse qui reste aujourd'hui en
vigueur à savoir celle d'un
déconfinement des sportifs
professionnels au 11 mai qui reprendrait
l'entraînement pendant un mois et donc
d'un déroulement des championnats du de
la mi juin jusqu'à la fin la fin juillet
devient de plus en plus hypothétique
puisque on voit que ça pose de multiples
questions qu'il va falloir voir ce qui
se passe dans l'est dans les jours qui
viennent pour voir si tout cela est
tenable
aujourd'hui ce qui est certain c'est que
parmi les autres sports professionnels
français
tous ont pris la décision de ne pas
jouer au minimum jusqu'au mois d'août et
il n'y a que le football aujourd'hui qui
restent encore accrocher à cet espoir de
pouvoir finir la saison d'ici la fin du
mois de juillet mais justement si le
sport reprend si le foot par exemple
reprend quelles conséquences d'un point
de vue sanitaire des matches à huis clos
pour éviter toute propagation du virus
pour avoir des recettes des droits tv
c'est peut-être ça le plus important
c'est ce qui va peut-être faire le rugby
avec les play-offs en fin août
christophe lepetit et évidemment que le
outre le fait de pouvoir mener une
compétition à son terme et de ne pas
trop remettre en cause l'équité sportive
bien qu'elle soit déjà remise en cause
quoi qu'il arrive guide les choix de la
lfp et des clubs mais qui a aussi des
considérations économiques
un club de football repose à près de la
moitié de ses revenus sur les droits
télé et c'est évident on voit la
position aujourd'hui des diffuseurs du
football français que ce soit canal+ et
vince sport que si les championnats ne
vont pas à leur terme on aura du mal à
percevoir le reliquat des droits télé
qui sont ils sont dus donc on s'accroche
à cet espoir de pouvoir jouer
l'intégralité des rencontres qui restent
à jouer et que ça permette justement de
toucher les droits télé restant à verser
pour la saison 2010 9 2020 sans trop
empiéter sur la saison 2020 2021 pour
pour ne pas non plus remettre en cause
le modèle économique de l'année
prochaine qui risque d'être très
fortement dégradé donc voilà c'est vrai
que ce sont des considérations
économiques qui aujourd'hui font que le
football qui est beaucoup plus télé
dépendants que les autres soient encore
dans cette volonté de vouloir essayer de
finir coûte que coûte et qui est aussi
écoute ce que lui dit de l'uefa qui
conseille jusqu'à présent de pouvoir
essayer de finir si possible les
compétitions domestiques avant la fin du
mois de juillet on parle beaucoup
d'économies dont tous à 1 gervais martel
qu'elle est conne et quelles
conséquences économiques de cette crise
pour vous à lens quel retour également
vous avez des autres clubs
un dépôt de bilan une cessation
d'activité c'est possible moi je pense
qu'il faut pas exagérer mais il ya quand
même une idée une chose qu'il faut
ajouter sur sur ce que vient de dire
monsieur petit celle ci aujourd'hui
manque à gagner qui va exister aussi
évidemment dans les recettes des stades
et dans le conte appelle communément les
pays paie ce qui reprend quand même une
grosse partie aussi des ressources du
club
la billetterie et les élèves et ip
malheureusement je pense je vois mal
demain matin les gens aller au stade
avec des masques ou aller dans les bars
les salles ont levé ip avec des masques
également donc ça c'est quand même en
plus des droits télévision ça va être
une contrainte
pour lui ce qui va arriver qui va
augmenter je dirais les difficultés
financières après dans l'est dans les
dents le revenir d'abord sur le jeu moi
je pense qu'il ferait bien d'arrêter le
championnat comme et comme ils l'ont
fait comme ils ont proposé en hollande
et en belgique joue à 22 ans rien ce
serait pas d'être dramatique pendant
pendant un an et touche à tout cas plus
de coupe de la ligue donc il peut on
peut très bien jouer à 22 et en faire
descendre quatre et pour se remettre car
et je dirais l'année suivante
je pense que ce serait beaucoup plus
sage maintenant comme l'a dit mon
interlocuteur c'est celle c'est le
gouvernement qui a décrit de façon de la
série 1 qui qui va dire un petit peu
comment ça va se passer ce qu'ils
proposent et les associations sportives
fédérations vont suivre des propositions
du gouvernement en ce qui concerne
l'aspect financier bien entendu c'est
compliqué parce qu'en plus qu'à la plus
élevée ils n'ont pas payé les sommes des
matchs joués et jusqu'à présent donc il
fera au moins récupérer ça et ensuite
après il va falloir revoir je pense une
grosse réflexion dans l'autre sur
l'économie du sport et notamment de
celles du football parce que c'est vrai
que ça me rend donc entraîner des
manques à gagner même si même s'il faut
relativiser ça parce que le nouveau
contrat signé avec media pro va ramener
4 400 millions ou 450 millions de
plusieurs coups de phrases et par an à
partir de l'année prochaine
donc je pense que rue moyenne avec la
prise du port anna virus mediapro il ya
beaucoup d'incertitudes autour de la
création de cette chaîne
selon elle va pas se créer cette chaîne
malgré tout ce qui se passe tu t'es si
les diapos n'existe plus dans deux mois
je réponds à skis mais ce qui me sens à
posséder ce que l'hétéro travail que le
foot espagnol
j'espère que la décaperie je dirais tous
les engagements et des assurances qu'ils
vont me dire aujourd'hui mais guère
profond va pas démarrer alors là je
crois qu'on peut atteindre le bouton de
la télé christophe lepetit
gervais martel a notamment parlé de la
billetterie vous dans vos déclarations
récemment vous avez tiré la sonnette
d'alarmé concernant des clubs de rugby
notamment je pense à à toulouse a
clairement à la rochelle qui t'a
beaucoup sur la billetterie il pouvait
il pourrait perdre gros selon vous ça
veut dire quoi moi je suis totalement en
accord avec gervais martel je pense
qu'il ya l'aspect droits télé qui est la
principale ressource des clubs
aujourd'hui mais c'est évident que on ne
reprendra pas le sport professionnel
dans des conditions normales donc
aujourd'hui on s'oriente vers des
matches à huis clos et peut-être ensuite
à des des matchs avec des jauges
inférieures à ce qu'elles sont
d'habitude ce qui veut dire qu'il va y
avoir d un énorme manque à gagner une
diminution importante des recettes des
clubs de temps sur la partie jour
recettes jours de match que sur la
partie sponsoring et c'est vrai que
j'avais eu l'occasion d'être interrogé
sur sur l'économie du rugby qui elle
dépend assez largement du sponsoring 40%
des recettes d'un club de top 14 yens du
sponsoring et et 13% des recettes jours
de match très clairement pour les clubs
de rugby qui sont plus dans cette
économie qu'on qualifie de réels
c'est-à-dire qui repose plus sur des
prestations qui sont vendus aux gens qui
assistent aux matchs que ce soit le
grand public où les spectateurs vip qui
viennent dans les espaces hospitalité et
qui payent pour avoir des prestations
des prestations de communication pour
ces clubs de rugby l'a effectivement si
on reprend à huis clos
ça peut être extrêmement compliqué mais
sa lettre ça le sera tout autant pour
les clubs de handball et pour les clubs
de la séance qui sont dans le même état
justement je voulais venir à tous ces
clubs
handball le basket le volley des clubs
peuvent mettre la clé sous la porte
peut-être suite à un désengagement des
sponsors on sait que ce sont souvent des
petites entreprises locales qui sont
partenaires
par exemple chez vous dans les hauts de
france gervais je pense à gravelines
dunkerque
en basket ou du sdk handball des
entreprises locales à laruns avec le
conte avec le confinement est ce que des
clubs de danse de basket ou de volley va
mettre la clé sous la porte
c'est pas impossible impossible mais
maintenant que la nature a horreur du
vide
malheureusement je dirais des clubs
céder sa c6 si le propos était un pas
les moyens financiers pour mais je crois
qu'il doit y avoir aussi je pense une
retraite réflexion sur le sueur sur le
sport en général et les dépenses dans le
sport aujourd'hui aujourd'hui ces
acteurs baseball c'est à peu près avec
les charges sociales les lamas sur elle
ses 60 à 70% du budget vous rendez
compte
donc aujourd'hui je pense qu'il va
falloir qu'on arrête un peu et pour dix
minutes peut-être certainement certains
salaires de joueurs qui me semble
excessif dans la situation mondiale
aujourd'hui vous me direz les rockeurs
vont continuer oui parce qu ils sont 25
ou 30 en europe vingtaine rose où un sac
se partager le gâteau sur les transferts
et des managers qui prennent beaucoup
d'argent sur ces affaires loeb mais
voilà que contre les souches moi ça fait
30 ans gt30 son président en 30 ans on
m'a dit les salaires vont baisser et
écoutez j'ai jamais vu à faire baisser
sans faute c'est maintenant aujourd'hui
ça passe quand même dans une situation
comme on est là c'est vrai qu'ils sont
exceptionnels mais ça pose quand même
des fesses ou qui que ce soit dans le
foot d'ailleurs et comme tu l'as dit
très justement dans les autres sports
c'est pareil on vole au volley au basket
donc on est vraiment peut-être un
tournant
on reparle du modèle économique
du sport en général c'est à cette crise
du corona virus dans un instant rester
sur arte france notre match revient tout
de suite de retour sur le plateau de
l'autre match on évoque les conséquences
de la crise du corona virus dans le
sport avec nos invités gervais martel ex
président du racing club de lens et
christophe le petit économiste du sport
gervais vous étiez en train de nous
parler du modèle économique du sport
christophe est ce que cette crise du
coronavirus ne peut pas relancer
complètement la machine pour revenir sur
des bases un petit peu plus raisonnables
alors je pense qu'il est là on a deux
phases qui vont se succéder on à la
phase actuelle qui est sur la gestion de
la crise on comment on fait en sorte
gérer au mieux la crise pour éviter
qu'ils aient le moins de morts possibles
tous sports confondus y compris dans le
football
et puis derrière c'est comment se
projette et ce derrière va venir assez
vite comment on se projette sur la plaie
nous on sait qu'au centre de droit et
d'économie du sport on pense et je crois
que ce que gervais a expliqué juste
avant revient un peu à ça que
globalement il faut revenir à un peu
plus de mesure
et qu'aujourd'hui peut-être que les
conditions sont réunies pour qu'on ait
une réflexion globale parce qu'elle peut
pas être que franco française cette
réflexion là évidemment mais qu on ait
une réflexion globale au niveau du
football pour le coût mondial sur goal
réduire les salaires skm bape et un
neymar va dire ok moi je mets cependant
salaires c'est que polygone que je vois
la ccc pas eu de sectaire que c'est pas
d'eux mêmes qu'ils vont accepter de
baisser leurs salaires
par contre si on met en place une
régulation beaucoup plus strictes au
niveau mondial a minima qui empêche les
clubs d'aller au delà d'un certain
niveau de dépenses salariales
de fait on limitera l'inflation des
salaires donc aujourd'hui
finalement il n'y a pas de limite à 7 à
cette augmentation des salaires parce
que l'économie du football elle est en
croissance très forte depuis depuis 25
ans et comme c'est une industrie de main
d'oeuvre et bien et les salariés en
l'occurrence des joueurs ont capté la
plus grosse part de cette de cette
économie là et parmi les joueurs se sont
évidemment les superstars qui ont capté
la plus grosse part mais ça a été rendue
possible parce qu'il ya eu une
dérégulation totale et libéralisation
d'une part du marché du travail qui a
fait que les joueurs n ont plus été du
tout contre un dans leur mouvement avant
avant 1995 avant bosman
on avait des limitations du nombre
d'étrangers par équipes aujourd'hui
c'est plus le cas on peut avoir des
équipes qui sont constitués de quasiment
que des étrangers que ce soit des extra
communautaires ou des joueurs
communautaire et donc du coup les clubs
les joueurs ont pu aller d'un endroit à
un autre et couplé à cette
libéralisation du marché du travail
vous avez eu une explosion des recettes
des clubs les recettes télévisuelles
puis maintenant des recettes
commerciales puisque les grands clubs se
finance de plus en plus par les gros
contrats de sponsoring est donc en fait
c'est là dessus qu'on n'a pas eu en face
à un mouvement de régulation
suffisamment strictes pour éviter
justement que que on aille dans une
surenchère permanente et qu'on offre des
salaires toujours plus fort donc moi je
pense qu'aujourd'hui les conditions sont
réunies pour avoir une négociation parce
que la crise elle touche tout le monde
on n'a pas une crise qui touche que les
clubs français et des clubs français qui
voudraient se faire hara kiri
les clubs anglais sont impactés les
clubs espagnols sont impactés les clubs
allemands le sont aussi
donc je pense j'espère en tout cas qu'on
peut avoir ce genre de discussion pour
revenir à plus de mesure et faire en
sorte de construire en fait un business
sera aussi plus durables et qu'ils
puissent se traverser de façon un peu
plus un peu plus sereine ce genre de
crise
pour vous comprendre schématiser en fait
c'est le monde du sport et notamment le
foot qui sont devenus une sorte de bulle
spéculative
les clubs pros ans et ils ont sollicité
l'aide de l'état pour bénéficier du
dispositif du chômage partiel en france
certains crient au scandale puisque le
contribuable va devoir payer des
sportifs qui sont souvent grassement
payés gervais est ce qu'on peut dire que
on marche sur la tête
non mais je pense que maintenant il faut
toujours du vent c'est quand les uns que
les autres
ni les les sujets des led et 10 juillet
du football bien évidemment on parlait
tout à l'heure qui sont concernés qui il
ya aussi pourquoi aller je le comprends
jusqu'où vont les choses dire aux
chiffres des joueurs de foot et j'en
connais moi qui gagne 5,6 mais cette
baie de 10000 euros donc notamment sur
la n2 et énormément de joueurs qui sont
à dix mille euros donc aujourd'hui qu'il
était une aide de l'état qui reprennent
avec la maximum sur montano et demi
quatre fois et demie le montant du sneg
moi je suis pas choqué parce qu'elles
sont des entreprises
n'oubliez pas que le foot c'est ça c'est
ça un apport considérable au niveau de
ce que laissent tout au niveau des pros
de ce qu'est ce que votre niveau de
l'emploi direct et indirect ça prend
quand même énormément toews de football
ne peut pas dire on met en met de côté
les fautes parce que c'est des gens trop
payés on peut pas eu des fautes c'est
pas possible
le foot c'était une économie comme une
autre qui fait vivre énormément de
personnes et je pense que c'est logique
que le photo même titre que d'autres
d'autres activités le sport d'ailleurs à
lomé leurs activités soient aidés dont
il faut pas avoir un raisonnement qui
soit simpliste son connaître l'ensemble
du problème justement à le foot français
est là le foot pro rhin à ligue 1 et
ligue 2 confondues
on peut voit dix mille personnes en
france dont 2000 à 2500 joueurs et puis
simplement pour pour nuancer
cette question évidemment ses 362
millions de charges patronales en 2018
pour pour le foot français c'est plus
que dassault systèmes par exemple 311
millions d'euros
mais gervais suite à cette crise est ce
que vous pourriez revoir à la baisse les
contrats de vos joueurs est ce qu'il ya
un salary cap
va-t-il voir le jour un peu comme aux
états unis je vais tout à fait prendre
goût je pense que il y aurait ce qui
m'inquiète beaucoup et on essayant
d'avoir une vision figée ou moyen terme
c'est j'espère très gros clubs ont pas
profité
deux soeurs parce qu'ils sont pas
touchés parce qu'ils auront des
investissements de chantiers importants
ils ont ils ont certainement et ils ont
des médecins qu'ils m'aident beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent grands
cétacés gros clubs ont pas profité de
cette situation pour relancer le serpent
mer pour ressortir pouvez tous les 4 5 6
mo qui est un championnat européen avec
les ventes avec eramet européen parce
que ce soit c'est catastrophique par
rapport au départ à l'idée que je me
fais du foot moi le foot ça reste une
notion de notions de le commentaire de
terrain de une nation une mesure jugée
très cocardier un petit mot là et j'ai
peur que peut être les soupçons qui sont
peu touchés c'est à dire les très gros
club avec des multimilliardaires qui
investissent dans le foot profitent de
simples et est passé de lancer une ligue
européenne privée et voudront de ça il
va falloir que tout le monde se met à
réfléchir
bien entendu il maintenant c'est pas
parce que il ya une crise aujourd'hui
que demain matin dès 10 ans vont être
qu'on sait on est on est on est un pays
est français mais je pense que l'homme
en général
souvent quand on est atteint par quelque
chose bon on réfléchit beaucoup qui
ensuite on n'en parle plus
quand lens est descendu en 2007-2008 en
seconde division j'avais prévenu tous
mes anciens collègues en disant il faut
absolument et d'être utile et sens que
ça peut vous arriver
tout le monde a dit oui tu as raison
j'avais accepté la décision a été prise
seulement pour l'est pour ceux qui vont
descendre la fin de cette saison si vous
voyez il y a failli il a fallu quatorze
ont donc moi je me méfie toujours des
bonnes paroles et ensuite quand la
machine est repartie mais où passer au
cloud
justement je vous propose deux passes
autre chose on a beaucoup parlé du foot
il ya d'autres événements qui ont été
annulés ou reportés on a parlé de l'euro
il ya les jo aussi il ya le tour de
france qui va quand même avoir lieu
cette année que se trouve le petit je
vous pose cette question pourquoi le
tour de france va avoir lieu cette année
du le 29 août pourquoi se passe car un
tissu économique plus locales
contrairement par exemple aux jeux
olympiques de tokyo
c'est parce qu'il ya un fort risque de
propagation qui peut peut-être se
produire également pendant ce tour de
france non alors à ce jour le tour de
france a été reportée effectivement avec
un départ qui est programmé le 29 août
rien ne nous assure rien ne garantit que
le tour de france tour de france ait
lieu parce qu'on n'est pas à l'abri
comme gervais il indiqué tout à l'heure
que une fois le déconfinement opéré eh
bien il ya une seconde vague plus ou
moins importantes qui qui ne remettent
tout en cause finalement cette cette
réouverture est ce cette relance des
événements sportifs
maintenant pourquoi est-ce qu'on a sauvé
le tour de france ou pourquoi on a
trouvé cette date pour le tour de france
oui parce que je pense que tour de
france à cet aspect c'est cette
particularité d'être un événement
sportif patrimonial qui est peut-être un
petit peu plus qu'un événement sportif
c'est une sorte de belles cartes
postales de la france et c'est vrai que
on a eu le sentiment qu'il fallait au
même titre que roland garros pour
d'autres raisons
essayer de sauver le tour de france est
donc on a décalé dans le temps dans un
horizon on espère que les conditions
sanitaires seront seront plus propices à
la réalisation de cet événement mais on
verra parce que rien ne nous garantit
effectivement que l'on soit vraiment en
mesure de pouvoir tenir cet événement là
dans de bonnes conditions sanitaires
ça ça va vraiment dépendre de
l'évolution un christophe lepetit
d'évoquer de parler de roland garros
gervais j'ai cette question est-ce qu au
rcl vous êtes assurés contre un risque
épidémique parce que wimbledon longtemps
notre tennis réguler et est assuré
pendant 17 ans ils ont payé 34 millions
de dollars sur 17 ans et au final ils
ont touché 141 millions de
dollars et noom notamment je suis dans
d'autres activités aussi dans le sport
notre organisation de contrôle adolphe
jamais réussi à monter des assurances
important parce que voilà j'aurais
simplement revenir insurgés sur ce qui
vient dit et bien dit juste avant moi je
pense pas que pour le retour à lyon je
suis désolé de vous dire que pour ça
mais si les coutumes comme ça où je
pense qu'on a fait c'est sûr seigner
presque ordinaire tous les français sont
attachés à surrey et on est on est on
est on est tous gérard autour de 30
et moi je me demande comment ça peut
s'organiser un tour de france avec des
étapes où les cours des plusieurs
équipes vont être d'en loger dans les
mêmes domaines par exemple parce que par
exemple il ya des villes étapes où il
n'y a pas non plus 40 hôtels de dollars
par an afin où on va toujours mettre les
x 1 par chambre comment ça va se passer
pour une caravane vous savez 80 tour de
france a des choses les plus appréciés
par spectateur où les gens sont un dû
signer dans des voitures pour pour
envoyer des objets publicitaires
franchement les des moments où je vous
parle enfin vrai que je me dis mais
comme aimer mais comment commence à
peine possible alors si c'est pour nous
donner un coup de réconfort c'est
extraordinaire mais franchement je vois
mal à autrui sur ce que j'entends et
quelles conséquences pour l'assurance
d'un point de vue général christophe le
paysage du rock pour une pop
on a beaucoup parlé d'un point de vue de
micro économie avec des clubs locaux
d'un point de vue plus macro économique
quelles conséquences notamment sur les
rebords des jeux olympiques et et de
l'euro qu'elle perde christophe lepetit
sur ces gros événement alors il ya deux
sujets il ya sujet de l'assurance
effectivement il ya très peu de très peu
d'assurance qui on est très peu
d'organisateurs qui ont pu réussir à
faire prendre en charge ce risque
épidémique est donc aujourd'hui et bien
se retrouve sans assurance par rapport à
ce qui leur arrive et dans les prochains
dans les prochains mois les prochaines
années ça risque de devenir très
compliqué d'assurer un tel risque parce
que justement le coronavirus sera passée
par là et que assurer un risque
épidémique maintenant ça risque s'était
déjà certainement très cher ça risque de
devenir hors de prix et donc
complètement inaccessible pour les
petits événements ou les petites
entreprises puisque ils vont parler de
la taille des entreprises et les clubs
de football qui sont parmi les plus gros
que les gros des plus grosses
entreprises histoire professionnelle ça
ne ce n'est ni plus ni moins que de ça
ne sont ni plus ni moins que les tpe
donc je pense pas qu'on pourra vraiment
prendre en charge ce risque là deuxième
élément c'est sur le coup le coup du
report des jeux c'est colossal
il est difficile de le chiffrer
aujourd'hui précisément mais j'ai vu
circuler quelques chiffres ont parlé de
quelque chose de l'ordre de 3 milliards
d'euros en fait de deux sur coup en se
demandant qui allait bien pouvoir le
prendre en charge
c'est évident qu'il ya surtout parce que
vous ne fait pas que décalé d'un an
en décalant d'un an vous allez retarder
le fait de rendre le village olympique a
fait des événements au promoteur
immobilier qui devait transformer deux
villages olympiques en bureau en
habitation etc
vous allez devoir rebloqué des chambres
paix des hôteliers que vous aviez bloqué
dans un an et c'est donc ça ça coûte
extrêmement cher
il va falloir voir qu'ils règlent la
facture pour les jeux olympiques qui
entre le 6 le comité international
olympique et tokyo 2020 va prendre en
charge ce surcoût pour l'uefa également
il y aura un surcoût assez important du
fait d'avoir des cadets l'euro de l'été
2020 elle était 2021 monsieur c
pratiquement la fin de cette émission
juste très très rapidement une note
d'espoir dans ce monde de brutes géré
mais j'espère que ça va se calmer et
véritablement moi je pense aussi
beaucoup aux gens qui ont été touchés
j'ai encore un ami qui est touché
aujourd'hui est on est on a vraiment
hâte que ça puisse se terminer et le
sport c'est la vie donc si on peut
retrouver tout ce qu'il est et rhin
vibrer pour nos potes passion savoure à
dire que la vie est redevenue normale
est et qu'on pourrait retrouver beaucoup
beaucoup de plaisir merci beaucoup
gervais martel d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes le
président historique du racing club de
france l'un des plus grands clubs de
foot du 2e cycle de l'eau à ses potes de
lens c'est parce que j'ai dit plus l'un
des plus grands clubs de france
champion de france en 98 merci beaucoup
gervais martel d'avoir répondu à nos
questions merci également christophe
lepetit d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes économiste du
sport ocde s de limoges restait
évidemment sur rt france vous pouvez
revoir évidemment cette émission en
podcast ou en replay sur arte france
pointe eveala quant à nous on se donne
rendez vous un petit peu plus tard sur
arte france by merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]